guys guess what today's the day I
finally got myself a standing desk for
the past few years I've been talking to
you guys and asking for suggestions on
which desks to get and the problem was I
really like the desks that I already
have so this is super exciting very desk
reached out and said hey we have a
solution for you this allows me to use
the desks that I already have so I can
basically turn this into a standing desk
or I can still sit down if I choose to
so a huge thank you to vary desk for
sponsoring this video
I can't wait to unbox this this is the
very desk Pro Plus 36 and what's great
about this one is it's made for dual
monitors they also have the pro plus 30
version which is good for single
monitors but as you guys can tell this
monitor is massive I also sometimes do
have dual monitors and I thought that
this is probably the best option for me
I am so excited about this I'm so
excited that I was actually looking up
standing facts did you guys know that
each hour of sitting erases 8% from the
health benefits of an hour of running
yeah I know so let's stop wasting time
and unbox this Maddie are you excited
about the very desk this is so mommy can
stand up Gabe I don't think I did notice
and this is way heavier than I thought
oh okay I'm completely doing this
totally wrong
I was definitely doing it wrong because
I was expecting that I was gonna have to
go get a toolkit and put stuff together
but this looks like it's already put
together I wish everything shipped like
this active workspace essentials oh
what's this
is this like a coaster to put my drink
oh I love cable wraps I'm not very good
with cable management as many of you
know these are great okay he looks happy
he looks healthy he looks like he's
really enjoying his work this is what I
like to see no tools required holds up
to 35 pounds with another person's
assistance oh I might need your
assistance Tyler the thing is this one
is actually made for a straight desk
they have another version too that's
made for curved desks but because this
curved desk I have is really deep this
should work with no problem but I was
really surprised how many accessories
they do have on the website if you guys
want to check it out for more
information on this or any of their
other products check out very desk comms
and LED lights they have a stool that's
over there that I'm gonna unbox in a
second I think they have so many things
let me through you little friend this
looks really well-made - which is good
because if you're putting your computer
or your monitor or something on this you
don't want it to feel like it's not
sturdy and this already feels like super
industrial that actually fits perfect so
there's little handles right you just
lift it up oh my gosh the whole thing
goes no way I thought this whole thing
stayed down okay I'm gonna put it back
down Oh what just snaps right in place
okay I'm gonna move my monitor up there
oh my gosh this looks perfect the one
thing that I was just thinking right now
is if I do turn this into the standing
option this cable is gonna be too short
but guess what there's also a solution
for that this is the very desk power hub
so it was a little bit concerned because
when this is in the standing mode the
cables that I have are plugged in pretty
low to the ground but this I can plug in
my Mac Mini which is what I'm editing
off of right now for this desk I can
plug the monitor in and this has just
like this little clamp so I can clamp it
to whatever I need like it can claim to
the desk it can clamp to the actual desk
itself yeah so does three plugs here it
also has two USB ports which is great as
well use clamp this to the desk I am so
glad I got this because I make so much
sense
my little Mac Mini right here you have
to work on my cable management back here
but it's looking good so far
this is a professional workplace
okay I'm gonna clean up a little and
finish the setup process it's almost
setup and look at this little loaf that
I found this is Maddy might take a look
at this desk see what you think what do
you think do you like it do you like it
that's the tails wagging that means yes
what do you think it is all set up I
love how easy this is to adjust the
different heights so if you are taller
you can make it whatever height you need
it to be I'm a little on the shorter
side so I'm gonna move it down just a
little but this is the height when it's
all the way up and from my height I'm
thinking right there this is nice
look at me typing now watch me type
let's watch a YouTube video shall we
let's see what John's been up to what's
up guys so right now I'm actually in
Yosemite National Park this she's in
Yosemite oh she changed her little
header little adventure girl okay so now
if I want to sit look at me sit now
watch me saying oh hey I'm loving this
so much I never thought that a standing
desk would be something that I needed
and now I feel like I can't live without
it it's only been an hour standing is
cool but I've also seen people in
offices they have like little chairs and
sometimes you can lean so they have a
very desk chair which is just over here
so I'm gonna just squeeze through here
also got a little mat for my little feet
this is so great
let's test out the chair this is already
put together - what I have to do
anything these are this is the best
unboxing I've ever experienced you so
cool now watch this I feel healthier
already so if I decide I want to sit pop
that down like my posture it feels I
feel good
so I know I've only been using this for
about 45 minutes but already I can tell
that I just feel more comfortable like
everything just feels like it should
like what I'm sitting in other chairs I
just don't feel comfortable
I like the mat too like my little toes
just feel super comfy it's like a nice
little squish oh another thing that's
good is if I have my macbook yeah this
is really great Madelene this is just
really awesome but I'm so excited about
this as an addition to my office but
also as an addition to my health because
I feel like I sit down so much like I am
at my computer wait too long sitting
down and just not really moving around
so this I already feel like I'm already
gonna be kind of like chillin lounging
I'll be standing up I'll be walking
around I also promise you guys some more
facts let me get you guys some facts
before I let you go
it is believed Shaq with glasses on I
mean glasses for this it is believed
that Leonardo da Vinci painted the Mona
Lisa at a standing desk as far back as
the 1400s Thomas Jefferson had a tall
desk designs of the heat could stand to
work on his blueprints
that's not it Charles Dickens Oh
Benjamin Franklin and Winston Churchill
are also reported to have preferred to
work at a standing desk you guys I've
been looking up so many standing desk
facts and that's what I like to do in my
free time so if you guys want to share
any standing desk facts with me below or
any health benefits that you guys have
found I would love to read those in the
comments below and now I'm gonna go
because clearly I've got a new toy that
needs to be tended to a huge thank you
to very desk again for sponsoring this
video you guys are amazing and if you
guys want to check out more information
about the desk or any of the accessories
check out the very desk comm I'll put a
link in the description okay it's just
actually the end of the video
[Music]